well x's johnny depp and amber hurd are
moving on in court as johnny's spending
habits come under fire
she didn't pay five million dollars to
blast hunter thompson's ashes out of a
cannon
not to my knowledge
depp's business manager testified about
amber's divorce demands
she was demanding 14 million and then it
got worse
also under intense scrutiny herds 2016
pledged to donate her entire 7 million
dollar settlement from johnny to two
charities including the aclu its ceo
says they've only received half
we
learned that she was having financial
difficulties he then dropped this
billionaire bomb the organization got
five hundred thousand dollars from elon
musk on amber's behalf why was mr musk
representing this on behalf of miss
heard i don't know the answer to that
question you'll remember johnny accused
herd of having an affair with twitter's
expected new owner which elon denied ms
heard had a relationship with mr elon
musk yes
yesterday the ex's former agent
christian carino testified amber and
elon did briefly date but after she and
johnny broke up the actor seemed
distressed and rubbed her eyes as her
texts with christian were read who she
was referring to when she was said here
i love him
johnny
miss
heard wanted to reconcile with mr duff
i believe
she did you seen all the crazy come out
amber is now getting slammed by team
johnny celebs including joe rogan who
blasted her on his podcast people that
are just completely manipulative and
fully like that like a crazy actress
clearly everyone's riveted with this
trial fans loved johnny's gummy bear
stash and this witness who started
driving and vaping during his deposition
which cracked depp up
that is the most bizarre episode okay i
just never seen that before don't miss
any trial moments by checking out our
live stream on entertainment tonight's
youtube channel
[Music]